I don't understand hunting.
To me, I love animals so much
that the thought of
shooting an animal,
I mean, it's a poor
little innocent animal
just standing around thinking
little deer thoughts, little,
"I wonder where
the berries are?"
"What's this on my hoof?"
Whatever they're
thinking, you know?
(audience laughs)
Always put their last expression
before being killed
on their wall.
This guy is proud of it.
(laughs)
Shot it! (laughs)
Killed it!
No, wasn't doing anything to
me, just standing there, why?
What's your point?
(audience laughs)
I could see if it was
something that you hated.
Something that you're really
proud that you killed,
like a hunter, actually,
now that I think about...
(audience laughs)
I mean...
(audience applauds)
(laughs)
Shot him.
(audience laughs)
I don't know, I ask people why
they have deer heads
on their walls,
they say because it's
such a beautiful animal.
There you go.
I think my mother's attractive,
but I have photographs of her.
(audience laughs)
Wasn't mom pretty?
She had great legs too.
They're in the
next room, come on.
(audience applauds)